>> THE LEADERSHIP OF MAINLAND
CHINA LIED ABOUT THIS VIRUS FROM
THE BEGINNING, THEY GUARANTEED
IT SPREAD ACROSS THE WORLD AND
DEVASTATE THE GLOBAL ECONOMY,
ALL OF WHICH HAPPENED.
WILL THEY PAY ANY PRICE FOR THAT
THAT?
ERIC SMITH IS THE
ATTORNEY GENERAL OF THE STATE OF
MISSOURI, THE FIRST STATE TO SUE
CHINA OVER THE WUHAN CORONAVIRUS
CORONAVIRUS.
TELL US ABOUT THIS SUIT THAT YOU
HAVE FILED.
>> IT’S BECOME CLEAR IN RECENT
WEEKS, THE DECEPTION AND
MISREPRESENTATION, THE
CONCEALMENT OF THE CHINESE
GOVERNMENT AND THE ORIGINS OF
THIS VICIOUS VIRUS, IT HAS
IMPACTED THE ENTIRE GLOBE, NO
PART OF THE WORLD HAS BEEN
SPARED FROM THE CORONAVIRUS.
THE FACT IS THE CHINESE
GOVERNMENT MISREPRESENTED THE
HUMAN TO HUMAN CONTACT AND
TRANSMISSION EARLY ON, THEY
PUNISHED AND CONCEALED THE
EVIDENCE FROM WHISTLE-BLOWERS
AND THE IMPACT HAS BEEN
DEVASTATING, LOSS OF LIFE IN
MISSOURI, NEARLY 6,000 CASES,
200 DEATHS.
PEOPLE NOT BEING ALLOWED TO SEE
FOLKS IN NURSING HOMES OR
FUNERALS, PEOPLE LIVING PAYCHECK
TO PAYCHECK AND HAVE LOST THEIR
JOBS -- -- IT’S ENORMOUS.
OUR STATE LEGISLATURE GOES IN
NEXT WEEK TO TRY TO CRAFT A
STATE BUDGET UNDER THE
CIRCUMSTANCES, I FELT IT’S
INCUMBENT UPON ME AS THE STATES
LEGAL OFFICER TO PROSECUTE THAT
CASE TO THE CHINESE GOVERNMENT.
THEY ARE RESPONSIBLE FOR THIS
AND THE RESPONSIBILITY LIES
DIRECTLY AT THEIR FEET.
>> Tucker: HAVE YOU HAD ANY
PUSHBACK OR DISAGREEMENT ON
THIS?
>> WE FEEL CONFIDENT IN THE CASE
CASE, THE HOARDING OF PPE IS ONE
OF OUR ALLEGATIONS AND TO SOME
FOLKS ARE BEING ISSUED AS TO THE
FEDERAL SOVEREIGN IMMUNITY ACT
BUT THERE ARE EXCEPTIONS.
THERE ARE EXCEPTIONS FOR
COMMERCIAL ACTIVITY, THE FACT
THAT THEY WERE RUNNING THE
VIROLOGY LAB, THEY WERE RUNNING
HOSPITAL SYSTEMS, HOARDING PPE,
WE THINK THAT’S IN THE EXCEPTION
WHICH IS WHY WE BROUGHT THE
CASE.
>> OTHER COUNTRIES HAVE BEEN
SUED SUCCESSFULLY, IRAN FOR
EXAMPLE.
REALLY QUICKLY, WHEN WILL YOU
FIND OUT IF THIS CASE GOES
FORWARD?
>> WE FILED TODAY IN THE EASTERN
DISTRICT IN FEDERAL COURT, WE
LOOK FORWARD TO THE CHINESE
GOVERNMENT’S RESPONSE.
THIS IS ABOUT HOLDING THOSE
RESPONSIBLE FOR THIS WORLDWIDE
PANDEMIC, HOLDING THEM
ACCOUNTABLE.
WE LOOK FORWARD TO THEM
ANSWERING THE COMPLAINT, IT’S
BEEN VERY SPECIFIC.
THE FACTUAL ALLEGATIONS AS FAR
AS THE TIMELINE AND
REPRESENTATIONS ARE VERY MERITED
MERITED.